สวัสดี ฉันชื่อ Olivia Lanes ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ Quantum Computing in Practice นี่คือตอนที่สอง Quantum
circuits เราจะครอบคลุมหัวข้อหลายอย่างในบรรยายวันนี้ แต่สิ่งที่ฉันอยากให้คุณจำได้คือสามอย่างนี้ หนึ่ง คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม IBM
จริง ๆ แล้วคืออะไร เพื่อให้คุณมีภาพคร่าว ๆ ในใจว่าคุณทำอะไรเมื่อส่ง job ไปยังมันผ่าน
cloud สอง Qiskit คืออะไร Primitive คืออะไร และวิธีใช้เพื่อสร้างและ execute quantum circuit
เราจะพูดถึงระดับสูงเกี่ยวกับประเภทต่าง ๆ ของโปรเซสเซอร์ IBM Quantum ที่มีและสิ่งที่แยกแยะหนึ่งจากอีกตัว และสาม
สุดท้าย เวิร์กโฟลว์ทั่วไปที่เราทำตามเพื่อรันการทดลองในระดับใหญ่ ซึ่งรวมถึงการเลือก Primitive ที่ดีที่สุด
สำหรับ use case ของคุณ การ map ปัญหาไปยัง quantum circuit และการใช้ error suppression และ mitigation ซึ่งช่วยให้
เราดึงพลังงานออกจากเครื่องเหล่านี้ให้ได้มากที่สุด มีข้อมูลมากมายที่นี่ แต่อยู่กับฉัน
เพราะในไม่ช้าเราจะนำทุกอย่างมารวมกันในบริบทของตัวอย่างจริง ๆ อย่างแรก มาพูดถึง qubit และ Quantum Hardware จริง ๆ กันสั้น ๆ
ในฐานะนักทดลอง ฉันรับประกันว่ามันน่าสนใจมากและช่วยเชื่อมโยงจุดต่าง ๆ ได้จริงเพื่อ
จินตนาการว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นจริง ๆ เมื่อส่ง job ไปยังคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมผ่านคลาวด์ โปรเซสเซอร์ที่
เราจะใช้สร้างด้วย superconducting transmon qubit นี่คือสิ่งที่โปรเซสเซอร์ IBM quantum ขนาดเล็กมองเห็น
สี่เหลี่ยมเล็ก ๆ เหล่านี้คือ qubit เอง รวมมีห้าตัวบนชิปนี้ transmon
เองคือตัวเก็บประจุและประกอบด้วยโลหะสองแผ่นเชื่อมต่อแบบ parallel กับตัวนำไฟฟ้าแบบ nonlinear ที่เรียกว่า
Josephson junction แต่เพื่อดู Josephson junction คุณต้องซูมเข้าไปอีก มันถูกสร้างจากสอง
layer ที่ทับซ้อนกันของโลหะ superconducting และที่ที่สองชิ้นทับซ้อนและสัมผัสกันคือ junction Josephson
Junction คือ element ที่ใช้สร้าง artificial atom ที่มีหลาย energy level และเรา isolate
สอง energy level ล่างเป็น qubit state เส้นหยัก ๆ ที่นี่แทน microwave resonator
โดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือสายส่ง 2D ที่เชื่อมต่อกับ qubit เมื่อเรา program gate มันโดยพื้นฐานแล้วเท่ากับการเลือก
microwave pulse ที่ calibrate อย่างแม่นยำ และ frequency, amplitude, รูปร่าง และระยะเวลาเฉพาะของ pulse เหล่านั้นทำให้
qubit ทำสิ่งเฉพาะ คำสั่งสำหรับ microwave pulse ไปจากคอมพิวเตอร์ของคุณไปยังคลาวด์ และ
จากนั้นถูกอ่านและตีความโดย room temperature control electronics ซึ่งรับคำสั่งเหล่านั้นและสร้าง pulse
ทางกายภาพ เราเรียกมันว่า microwave pulse เพราะทั้งหมดอยู่ใน microwave frequency bandwidth
ซึ่งอยู่ประมาณ 1 GHz หลังจาก room temperature control box สร้าง pulse แล้ว มันเดินทางผ่านสาย
ไปยัง dilution refrigerator และในที่สุดไปถึง quantum chip ของเรา signal ไปเข้า resonator ผ่าน
wire bond บน pad เหล่านี้แล้วไหลลงสาย transmission line ไปยัง qubit ของเรา ฉันรู้ว่าทั้งหมดนี้อาจ
ดูเป็นเรื่องทางเทคนิคและรายละเอียดเหล่านี้ไม่ได้สำคัญที่สุดสำหรับเราในการก้าวต่อไป แต่หวังว่าตอนนี้คุณ
ทุกคนอย่างน้อยก็นึกภาพระบบทางกายภาพที่คุณกำลังจะโต้ตอบด้วยได้ แล้วคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเหล่านี้
อยู่ที่ไหน IBM มีคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมหลายสิบเครื่องทั่วโลก และเราเพิ่งอัพเกรด fleet ของเราเพื่อ
มีแต่โปรเซสเซอร์ที่มีมากกว่า 100 qubit อย่างที่พูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อน บางส่วนอยู่ใน IBM
Quantum data center ใน Upstate New York ระบบเหล่านั้นถูก deploy บนคลาวด์สำหรับทุกคนใช้ และบางส่วน
เป็น dedicated on-premise system พร้อม electronics ทั้งหมดที่ทำงานให้รองรับ partner ของเรา
ใน IBM Quantum Network ตอนนี้มาพูดถึง Qiskit ซึ่งเป็น open-source software development kit ของ IBM
ที่ออกแบบมาทำงานกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ต่อจากนี้ฉันจะเรียกมันว่า Qiskit SDK มียัง
Qiskit ecosystem ซึ่งเป็นชุด software, tutorial และ function ที่สร้างบนหรือขยาย functionality หลักของ Qiskit รวมถึง Qiskit
runtime ซึ่งเป็น Quantum Computing service และ programming model ที่ให้ผู้ใช้ออกแบบและ
execute quantum workload อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพโดยใช้ Qiskit Primitive และ Primitive คือ building block เล็ก ๆ ที่
ใช้ออกแบบ circuit หรือ job ขนาดใหญ่ขึ้น Primitive สองตัวที่สำคัญที่สุดสำหรับเราคือ
sampler และ estimator ซึ่งจะพูดถึงในเชิงลึกเร็ว ๆ นี้ ถ้ายังไม่ได้ดาวน์โหลดและติดตั้ง
Qiskit SDK ไม่มีเวลาดีกว่านี้แล้ว Qiskit 1.0 เพิ่งเปิดตัวและ performative และ
stable กว่าที่เคยเป็น ดังนั้นสำหรับผู้ที่เพิ่งเริ่มต้น คุณมาในเวลาที่เหมาะสมมาก สำหรับผู้ที่
คุ้นเคยกับ Qiskit แล้ว คุณต้องดาวน์โหลดและติดตั้ง version ใหม่ล่าสุด เราแนะนำให้ใช้
pip เพื่อติดตั้ง Qiskit และ Qiskit runtime และรันผ่าน Jupyter notebook ในเบราว์เซอร์ที่คุณเลือก คุณยังต้องการ
ติดตั้ง Jupyter notebook หรือ JupyterLab ในกรณีที่ยังไม่ได้ทำ เครื่องมือเหล่านี้ทั้งหมดฟรีและ
คุณสามารถตั้งค่าและรันบนเครื่อง local ของคุณเองโดยไม่มีค่าใช้จ่าย แน่ใจว่าเพิ่ม Qiskit พร้อม
visualization option dependency เพื่อให้ทำงานกับ Jupyter และ plot ได้ คุณยังต้องตั้งค่า virtual python environment และมี
คำแนะนำวิธีทำสิ่งนี้บนหน้าติดตั้ง Qiskit ที่ลิงก์ที่นี่ เมื่อคุ้นเคยกับ Qiskit และพร้อม
รัน job บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริง คุณต้องลงทะเบียนที่ quantum.com และสร้าง IBM Quantum
API token และมีลิงก์ที่นี่สำหรับสิ่งนั้นด้วย คำแนะนำโดยละเอียดวิธีทำสิ่งนี้ตามคำสั่งทั้งหมดใน
หน้า documentation ของเรา อย่างที่พูดถึง หรือดูวิดีโอการติดตั้ง Qiskit ที่นี่
ทั้งสองอย่างลิงก์ไว้ในคำอธิบาย ตอนนี้เราเกือบพร้อมเริ่มพูดถึง Quantum
circuit เนื่องจากจุดประสงค์ของคอร์สนี้คือสอนคุณผู้ชมวิธี scale up job ให้รันที่ระดับ 100 qubit ขึ้นไป
ฉันคิดว่าวิธีที่สร้างสรรค์ที่สุดคือการพิจารณา เวิร์กโฟลว์โดยรวมที่เราจะทำตาม และวิธีที่ง่ายที่สุดที่จะ
เข้าใจเวิร์กโฟลว์ Quantum Computing ทั่วไปคือผ่าน Qiskit patterns Qiskit patterns คือ framework เชิงแนวคิดที่ให้ผู้ใช้รัน Quantum
workload โดย implement ขั้นตอนบางอย่างด้วย modular tooling สิ่งนี้ให้ Quantum Computing task ทำได้โดย
heterogeneous computing infrastructure ที่ทรงพลัง ขั้นตอนเหล่านี้สามารถทำเป็น service และ
รวม resource management ซึ่งช่วยให้ความสามารถใหม่ ๆ composable ได้อย่างราบรื่นเมื่อพัฒนาขึ้น นี่
คือขั้นตอนหลักที่ผู้ใช้ Qiskit ที่มีประสบการณ์น่าจะจำได้ ขั้นตอนแรกคือ mapping ขั้นตอนนี้
ทำให้ชัดเจนว่าเราต้องนำปัญหาทั่วไปที่สนใจไปยัง quantum computer
ในรูปแบบของ circuit อย่างไร ถัดไปเรา optimize ในขั้นตอนนี้เราใช้ Qiskit transpiler เพื่อ route และ lay out
circuit บน quantum hardware จริง ๆ ซึ่งรวมถึงการแปล Quantum Gate แต่ละตัวเป็นลำดับ
ของ operation ที่ทำบน hardware รวมถึงการ optimize layout ของ gate เหล่านั้น ถัดไปเรา
execute Qiskit runtime Primitive ให้ interface กับ IBM Quantum Hardware ที่ให้ transpiled circuit รัน
ขั้นตอนนี้ยังรวมถึงการใช้เทคนิค error suppression และ mitigation ซึ่งส่วนใหญ่ abstract ออกไปจากผู้ใช้ สุดท้ายเรา postprocess ใน
ขั้นตอนนี้ข้อมูลจากโปรเซสเซอร์ควอนตัมเองถูกประมวลผล ให้ผลลัพธ์ที่มีประโยชน์แก่ผู้ใช้สำหรับปัญหาเดิม โดยพื้นฐานแล้วขั้นตอนนี้
ครอบคลุมการวิเคราะห์ข้อมูลเพิ่มเติมที่ได้มา ตอนนี้เราพร้อมพูดถึงรากฐานของ quantum
program ซึ่งก็คือ quantum circuit หวังว่าคุณคุ้นเคยกับ quantum circuit แล้ว แต่ถ้าไม่ อาจต้องดูบทเรียน
ที่สาม Quantum circuits ซึ่งเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของ Understanding Quantum Information and Computation ที่ลิงก์ด้านล่าง
เราจะทบทวนสั้น ๆ ที่นี่เท่านั้น quantum circuit คือ network ของ quantum gate และ measurement ที่เชื่อมโยง
ด้วยสายที่แทน qubit quantum circuit อ่านได้เหมือนโน้ตดนตรีจากซ้ายไปขวา เริ่มที่
Time Zero ซึ่งอยู่ซ้ายสุด virtual qubit หมายถึง qubit ที่ยังไม่ได้ถูก assign ไปยัง physical
qubit จริง ๆ บนโปรเซสเซอร์ ถูกแสดงตามลำดับจากบนลงล่าง เมื่อตั้งค่า circuit แล้ว สามารถเพิ่ม
gate ได้ single qubit gate เช่น Hadamard gate ที่นี่ ส่งผลต่อ qubit ที่มันวางอยู่บน qubit หลาย
qubit gate เช่น CNOT ส่งผลต่อสองหรือมากกว่า qubit ที่เชื่อมโยงด้วย gate ในตัวอย่างนี้ state ของ qubit หนึ่งเปลี่ยนแปลง
ตาม state ของ qubit ศูนย์เป็น หลังจาก gate ทั้งหมดถูก apply แล้ว เราสามารถทำการวัด
ซึ่งทำให้ผลลัพธ์ถูกเขียนลงบน classical register ลักษณะสำคัญหนึ่ง
ของ circuit คือ depth ของ quantum circuit คือจำนวนขั้นต่ำของ layer ของ quantum gate ที่ execute
แบบ parallel ที่จำเป็นเพื่อทำการคำนวณที่นิยามโดย circuit ให้ชัดเจนว่า Quantum gate สามารถ execute
แบบ parallel หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือในเวลาเดียวกันได้ เมื่อไม่มี qubit ร่วมกัน แต่ถ้าสองหรือมากกว่า
gate กระทำต่อ qubit เดียวกัน เราทำมัน parallel ไม่ได้ ต้องทำทีละตัว เพราะ quantum gate ต้องใช้เวลาใน
การ implement depth ของ circuit โดยคร่าว ๆ สอดคล้องกับเวลาที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมต้องการ execute
circuit ดังนั้นการรู้ depth ของ circuit สำคัญสำหรับรู้ว่าสามารถใช้รันบนอุปกรณ์เฉพาะหรือไม่ มันยังบอกด้วยว่า
มีโอกาสดีในการให้ผลลัพธ์ที่แม่นยำ ถัดไปมาพูดถึงการเลือก quantum processor IBM
เพิ่งเปิดตัว fleet ใหม่ทั้งหมดของโปรเซสเซอร์ที่มีมากกว่า 100 qubit ทั้งหมด และคุณสามารถล็อกอินที่ quantum.com เพื่อดู
ว่าคุณมีสิทธิ์เข้าถึงโปรเซสเซอร์ใดบ้าง โปรเซสเซอร์ทั้งหมดตั้งชื่อตามนก ด้วยเหตุผลหนึ่ง และ logo ต่าง ๆ
แทนโปรเซสเซอร์ประเภทต่าง ๆ ตัวอย่างเช่น ตัวเหล่านี้แทน Eagle processor และ icon นี้คือ
heron ชื่อเฉพาะของโปรเซสเซอร์ก็พบที่ด้านบนด้วย ทั้งหมดตั้งชื่อตามเมือง แต่นั่น
ไม่ได้หมายความว่าโปรเซสเซอร์อยู่ที่เมืองนั้นจริง ๆ นั่นเป็นแค่ชื่อ จำนวน qubit,
EPLG และ CLOPS ก็เป็น factor ทั้งหมดที่แสดงไว้ เราจะอธิบายแต่ละอย่าง
qubit ตอนนี้ค่อนข้างชัดเจน qubit คือจำนวน qubit ทั้งหมดที่ใช้ได้บนโปรเซสเซอร์ควอนตัมเดียวนั้น หรือ
QPU EPLG ย่อมาจาก errors per layered gate ซึ่งวัด average gate process error ใน layered chain ของ
100 qubit โดยพื้นฐานแล้วต้องการให้น้อยที่สุด CLOPS ย่อมาจาก circuit layer operations per second และ
วัดว่า quantum volume circuit ที่เป็น virtual circuit มีกี่ layer ที่ QPU execute ได้ต่อหน่วยเวลา
ยิ่งสูงคำนวณได้เร็วขึ้น นี่เทียบเท่ากับ FLOPS ใน classical computing ตอนนี้ metric
ต่าง ๆ เหล่านี้อาจสำคัญมากหรือน้อยขึ้นอยู่กับพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันเฉพาะที่คุณสนใจ ถัดไปมาพูดถึงระดับสูง
การ map ไปยัง quantum circuit ขั้นตอนแรกคือ mapping ซึ่งโดยพื้นฐานตอบคำถามว่า
ฉันจะแปลปัญหาของฉันเป็น quantum circuit ที่รันบน quantum hardware ได้อย่างไร ไม่ต้องสงสัยเลย
mapping เป็นปัญหาที่ยาก และเป็นพื้นที่วิจัยที่ active อยู่ บางครั้งแค่นำปัญหาการคำนวณ
มาสร้างลำดับ quantum gate เพื่อช่วยแก้มัน นั่นคือส่วนที่ยากที่สุด ไม่มีวิธี foolproof
ที่รับประกันความสำเร็จ แต่มีแนวทางที่แนะนำและตัวอย่างปัญหาที่เรารู้วิธี
map แล้ว แนวทางแรกคือให้คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกทำงานที่มันทำได้ดีกว่าเอง งาน
ที่ง่ายสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก น่าจะไม่ได้ประโยชน์จากคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสำหรับปัญหาที่ classically ยาก
แน่นอนถ้านี่เป็นครั้งแรกที่ใช้ Qiskit หรือคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ไม่ต้องกังวลเรื่องหาปัญหาที่ซับซ้อนทางการคำนวณ แบ่ง
เป็นปัญหาย่อย ๆ ที่คุณเรียนรู้ได้ก่อนที่จะไปทำโปรเจกต์ utility scale ถัดไป แปล
ผลลัพธ์สำหรับปัญหาของคุณที่ต้องการวัดหรือเข้าใจเป็น expectation value หรือ sampling
สำหรับปัญหาส่วนใหญ่ สิ่งนี้โดยพื้นฐานสอดคล้องกับการคำนวณ cost function ซึ่งเป็น
function เฉพาะปัญหาที่นิยามเป้าหมายของปัญหาเป็นสิ่งที่ต้องการ minimize หรือ maximize และสามารถ
ใช้ดูว่า trial state หรือ solution ทำได้ดีแค่ไหนเทียบกับเป้าหมายนั้น
ความคิดนี้สามารถนำไปใช้กับแอปพลิเคชันต่าง ๆ ในเคมี machine learning การเงิน การ optimize และอื่น ๆ
อย่าลืมด้วยว่า hardware ที่จะใช้มี topology เฉพาะ qubit บางตัวไม่ได้เชื่อมต่อกัน
และในที่สุดคุณต้อง map ปัญหาของคุณไปยัง circuit ที่แทนสิ่งนี้ IBM Quantum processor
ใช้ heavy hex topology ซึ่งโดยพื้นฐานเท่ากับการเชื่อมต่อ qubit ใน hexagonal lattice ซึ่ง
จะพูดถึงเพิ่มเติมในคอร์ส ตอนนี้สิ่งสำคัญที่สุดคือ stage นี้ต้องการ
การฝึกฝน คุณต้องเข้าใจทั้งปัญหาของคุณและความสามารถของ quantum hardware
และเราจะดูตัวอย่างและ use case เฉพาะในภายหลังเพื่อดูวิธีสมดุลสิ่งเหล่านี้ได้
ดี ตอนนี้มาพูดถึงวิธี optimize circuit สำหรับ hardware ที่เลือก เป้าหมายโดยรวมของ
optimization step คือการ map virtual qubit ทั้งหมดจาก circuit ไปยัง real qubit จริงที่ไหนสักแห่งบน
topology ของโปรเซสเซอร์ เกมนี้คือการลด error ให้มากที่สุด เพื่อทำสิ่งนี้เราต้อง
route และ lay out circuit อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพก่อน สิ่งแรกต้องจำคือไม่ใช่ qubit ทุกตัวที่เชื่อมต่อกัน
อย่างที่บอกไปแล้ว บางตัวอยู่ห่างกันจริง ๆ บนชิป ดังนั้นต้องลดหรือกำจัด long-distance
interaction เมื่อเป็นไปได้ คุณสามารถ apply ลำดับ swap gate ระหว่าง qubit ที่อยู่ใกล้กันเพื่อย้าย qubit
information รอบ ๆ แต่ swap gate แพงและเกิด error ง่าย ดังนั้นอาจมีวิธีที่ดีกว่า ถัดไป layout
และ routing เป็นกระบวนการ iterative และมัน assign virtual qubit ของ circuit บน physical qubit บน
hardware คุณสามารถทำสิ่งนี้ด้วยมือ แต่ยังมีเครื่องมือใน Qiskit ที่สามารถแนะนำ physical
qubit layout ตาม error rate โดยประมาณ ถัดไปเราสามารถรวมลำดับ single qubit gate ที่กระทำต่อ qubit เดียวกัน
เป็น gate เดียว และยังบางครั้งสามารถกำจัด gate ที่ไม่จำเป็นหรือชุด gate ได้ เช่น
บางชุดของ gate สามารถลดเป็นชุดที่ง่ายกว่า และบางครั้งชุด gate แม้แต่
เท่ากับ identity operator ง่าย ๆ ดังนั้นเราสามารถกำจัดมันได้เลย คุณสามารถทำสิ่งนี้อัตโนมัติโดยใช้
Qiskit transpiler หรือทำมือแบบ gate ต่อ gate ถ้ามีเหตุผลดีและต้องการ
ควบคุมมากขึ้น เมื่อปรับปรุง circuit layout, routing และ gate count ไม่ว่าจะด้วยมือหรือ Qiskit transpiler แล้ว
เรามักต้องการ visualize circuit เพื่อแน่ใจว่า timing ของ gate ทั้งหมดสมเหตุสมผล มี argument ที่สามารถ flag ใน transpiler เพื่อ
visualize timeline ของ circuit และแน่ใจว่าทุกอย่าง align ตามที่คาดหวัง ตอนนี้มาพูดถึง error
suppression Error suppression หมายถึงเทคนิคต่าง ๆ ที่ transform circuit ระหว่าง compilation เพื่อลด error
มันต่างจาก error mitigation ซึ่งเกิดขึ้นหลังจาก circuit รันแล้ว และเราจะมาถึงตรงนั้นในไม่ช้า สองรูปแบบที่พบบ่อยที่สุดของ
error suppression ที่เราใช้ประโยชน์คือ dynamical decoupling และ Pauli twirling มีรายละเอียดเชิงเทคนิค
ที่นี่ แต่สามารถกลับมาดูทีหลังได้เสมอ ดังนั้นอย่างแรก dynamical decoupling ใช้เพื่อ
ยกเลิก noise บางส่วนที่กระทบ qubit โดย apply ชุด gate ที่รวมกันเท่ากับ
identity operation เช่น XX sequence และผลสุทธิคือการยกเลิก noise channel ที่กระทบ
qubit โดยประมาณ Pauli twirling คือวิธีแทรก random gate เพื่อทำให้ noise เฉลี่ยง่ายขึ้น ความสุ่มช่วย
ป้องกันไม่ให้ผลจาก error ต่าง ๆ สะสมเร็ว และยังทำให้ noise ง่ายต่อการระบุ
ตอนนี้วิธีนี้ยังเป็นพื้นฐานของเทคนิค error mitigation และเราจะพูดถึงมันในภายหลัง
อีกครั้ง มีข้อมูลมากมายที่นี่และไม่ต้องกังวลถ้าทุกอย่างยังไม่ซึมซับ โชคดีที่หลายส่วนทำอัตโนมัติได้โดยใช้ Qiskit
transpiler การ transpile อาจยุ่งยากอยู่บ้าง แต่ transpilation เป็นขั้นตอนสำคัญมากที่จะได้ utility ในระดับใหญ่
ซึ่งต้องการการลองผิดลองถูกมากเพื่อเชี่ยวชาญและได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดีที่สุด ตอนนี้ฉันอยากหยุดพัก
เล็กน้อยเพื่อพูดถึง Qiskit transpiler และความสามารถของมันมากขึ้น ฉันจะทำในระดับสูงมากและจะเข้าสู่รายละเอียดและดู
ตัวอย่างในภายหลัง โดยทั่วไป transpilation คือกระบวนการเขียน input circuit ใหม่เพื่อให้ตรงกับ
topology และ quantum device เฉพาะ และ optimize circuit สำหรับการ execute และความทนทานต่อ noise มันยัง
เขียน circuit ให้อยู่ใน basis gate ของ quantum processor เฉพาะที่คุณเลือกใช้ Qiskit มีสี่
built-in transpilation pipeline และถ้าคุณไม่คุ้นเคยกับ quantum circuit optimization ฉันแนะนำอย่างยิ่งให้ใช้หนึ่งใน
built-in pipeline เหล่านั้น โดย default transpiler รวมหกขั้นตอนเหล่านี้ คือ initialization,
layout, routing, translation, optimization และ scheduling initialization หมายถึง
pass เริ่มต้นใด ๆ ที่จำเป็นก่อนเริ่ม embed circuit บน backend โดยทั่วไปจะ
unroll custom instruction และแปลง circuit เป็นแค่ one และ two qubit gate ขั้น layout
apply layout mapping virtual qubit ใน circuit ไปยัง physical qubit บน backend routing รันหลังจาก layout ถูก
apply และแทรก gate เช่น swap gate เข้าไปใน circuit เดิมเพื่อให้ compatible กับ backend
connectivity ขั้นที่สี่คือ translation ใน stage นี้ gate ใน circuit ถูกแปลไปยัง target
backend basis set ถัดไปคือ optimization stage นี้รัน optimization loop หลัก
ซ้ำ ๆ จนกว่าจะตรงตามเงื่อนไข เช่น การถึง target depth บางอย่าง เรามีสี่ optimization
level ที่เลือกได้ สุดท้ายคือ scheduling stage นี้สำหรับ hardware-aware scheduling pass ใน
ระดับสูง scheduling คิดได้ว่าเป็นการแทรก delay เข้าใน circuit เพื่อจัดการ idle time บน qubit
ระหว่างการ execute instruction อย่างที่บอก มีสี่ optimization level ตั้งแต่ 0 ถึงสาม ที่
optimization level สูงกว่าใช้เวลาและความพยายามในการคำนวณมากขึ้น แต่อาจได้ circuit ที่ดีกว่า
Optimization level ศูนย์มุ่งหมายสำหรับการทดลอง device characterization และด้วยเหตุนั้นจะ map input circuit ไปยัง
constraints ของ target backend เท่านั้น ไม่ทำ optimization ใด ๆ Optimization level สาม
ใช้ความพยายามมากที่สุดใน optimize circuit อย่างไรก็ตาม เนื่องจากเทคนิค optimization หลายอย่างใน
transpiler ใช้ heuristic การใช้ความพยายามในการคำนวณมากขึ้นไม่ได้ทำให้
output circuit ดีขึ้นเสมอไป ถ้าสนใจเพิ่มเติม ดูหน้า transpiler ใน Qiskit
documentation ที่ลิงก์ด้านล่าง ตอนนี้เราพร้อมพูดถึงการ execute quantum circuit จริง ๆ
Qiskit runtime Primitive ให้ interface กับ IBM Quantum hardware และยัง abstract error
suppression และ mitigation ออกไปจากผู้ใช้ sampler primitive ให้ quasi-probability distribution หรือ count
ที่แทนความน่าจะเป็นของการวัด bit string บางตัวเป็นศูนย์และหนึ่ง estimator primitive ให้ expectation
value ของ observable ที่สอดคล้องกับปริมาณทางฟิสิกส์ ดังนั้นในรายละเอียดมากขึ้นนิดหน่อย sampler รัน circuit
หลายครั้งบน quantum device ทำการวัดในแต่ละรัน และสร้าง probability
distribution จากการ recover bit string เหล่านั้น ยิ่งรันหรือ shot มากขึ้น ผลลัพธ์ยิ่ง
แม่นยำขึ้น แต่ต้องใช้เวลาและ Quantum resource มากขึ้น โดยเฉพาะมันคำนวณ
ความน่าจะเป็นของการได้ standard basis state ที่เป็นไปได้แต่ละตัวโดยวัด state ที่ circuit เตรียมไว้ Qiskit
estimator ใช้กระบวนการทางพีชคณิตที่ซับซ้อนเพื่อ estimate expectation value บน real quantum device โดย
แตก observable ออกเป็นชุดของ observable อื่น ๆ ที่มี eigenbasis ที่รู้จัก และรัน ภายใน
Primitive คือเทคนิคที่เรียกว่า error mitigation error mitigation เป็น umbrella term สำหรับทั้งหมดนี้ และ
โดยพื้นฐานหมายถึงเทคนิคที่ช่วยลด circuit error โดยสร้างแบบจำลอง device noise ณ เวลา
execution โดยทั่วไปส่งผลให้เกิด Quantum pre-processing overhead ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับการ train model และ classical
post-processing overhead เพื่อ mitigate error ใน raw result โดยใช้ model ที่สร้าง แต่แลกกับ
overhead นี้ เราได้ผลลัพธ์ที่แม่นยำขึ้นมาก มีเทคนิคหลายอย่างที่ implement ได้สำหรับ
error mitigation และเราจะดูสามอย่างในรายละเอียดมากขึ้น แต่รู้ไว้ว่านี่เป็นพื้นที่
วิจัยที่ active อยู่ ดังนั้นเทคนิคใหม่น่าจะถูกประดิษฐ์และเทคนิคเก่าจะพัฒนาต่อ resilience
level เพิ่มต้นทุน หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือเวลาในการรัน job เราบอกแล้วว่าที่
resilience level ศูนย์ transpiler ไม่ทำอะไรกับ circuit ของคุณจริง ๆ แต่เริ่มที่ resilience level หนึ่ง มันแนะนำวิธีที่เรียกว่า twirled
readout error extinction หรือเรียกสั้น ๆ ว่า T-REx Twirled readout error extinction ใช้ Pauli twirling เพื่อ
mitigate noise ซึ่งเราได้พูดถึงแล้ว เป็นเทคนิคที่ทั่วไปและมีประสิทธิภาพมาก
ที่พูดอย่างเข้าใจง่ายทำให้ noise ผิดปกติน้อยลงและจัดการได้ง่ายขึ้น เริ่มที่ resilience level สอง
เราแนะนำ zero noise extrapolation หรือ ZNE นี่เป็นเทคนิคที่ได้รับความสำเร็จมากเมื่อเร็ว ๆ นี้
ไอเดียเบื้องหลัง ZNE อาจน่าแปลกใจ เราจริง ๆ เพิ่ม
noise เพิ่มเติมบนสิ่งที่มีอยู่แล้ว แต่สิ่งที่ทำให้คือช่วยให้เรา extrapolate ในทิศทางย้อนกลับเพื่อ
ทำนายว่าผลลัพธ์จะเป็นอย่างไรถ้า noise น้อยกว่า สิ่งนี้ทำได้หลายวิธีเฉพาะ เช่น
ยืด gate ให้ยาวขึ้นและด้วยเหตุนั้นจึง error ง่ายขึ้น หรือรัน gate มากขึ้นที่ในที่สุดส่งผลให้
เป็น identity operation ดังนั้น circuit ไม่เปลี่ยน functionally แต่เราสุ่ม noise มากขึ้นโดยตั้งใจ คุณต้องทำสิ่งนี้
สำหรับทุก circuit และทุก expectation value ที่ต้องการติดตาม ดังนั้น
คุณเห็นว่ามันอาจแพงมากในแง่เวลาที่ต้องการ ZNE ประเภทหนึ่งเรียกว่า
probabilistic error amplification หรือ PEA เมื่อเรียนรู้ noise model สำหรับ gate แล้ว PEA ทำงานโดย sample
error จาก noise model นั้นและแทรกเข้าไปใน circuit โดยตั้งใจ อย่างที่พูดถึง เทคนิคใหม่มากมาย
ยังคงพัฒนาต่อเนื่อง มีแค่รูปแบบสุดท้ายของ
error mitigation ที่อยากพูดถึง เรียกว่า probabilistic error cancellation แทนที่จะอยู่ที่ resilience level ที่สาม
PEC เป็น capability พิเศษที่ต้องเปิดใช้งานด้วยตัวเองใน Qiskit เพราะ resource การคำนวณ
ที่ต้องการมัน scale ได้ไม่ดีนักเทียบกับเทคนิค error mitigation อื่น ๆ ที่พูดถึง คุณ
เริ่มด้วยการเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับ noise ที่กระทบ circuit ของคุณโดยรัน noise learning หรือ noise characterization
circuit สำหรับแต่ละ layer ที่ unique ของ two qubit gate ที่อยู่ใน circuit ผลลัพธ์เหล่านี้ให้คุณอธิบาย noise
ในรูปของ Pauli operator เมื่อรู้ noise term เหล่านี้ คุณสามารถปรับ circuit เพื่อ
ให้ circuit มีสิ่งตรงข้ามกับ PEC ที่ built-in เพื่อยกเลิก noise channel เหล่านี้ ในบางแง่
กระบวนการนี้คล้ายกับหูฟังตัดเสียงรบกวน อย่างไรก็ตาม วิธีการ undo noise นี้มีต้นทุนสูงมาก โดยเวลา
รันจะเติบโต exponentially ตามจำนวน gate ดังนั้นอาจไม่ใช่ทางเลือกที่ดีที่สุดสำหรับ circuit ขนาดใหญ่มาก
ตอนนี้เราถึง stage สุดท้ายแล้ว postprocessing ในตอนท้าย ถ้าทำได้ดีและใช้ error
mitigation ที่ถูกต้อง คุณอาจเห็น final answer shift เหมือนในรูปที่นี่ unmitigated distribution
ที่แสดงในสีม่วงอยู่ห่างจาก true expected value ที่แสดงที่นี่ด้วยเส้นนี้มาก อย่างไรก็ตาม เมื่อ apply error
mitigation แล้ว เราได้ mitigated distribution ที่แสดงที่นี่ในสีน้ำเงิน ซึ่ง peak ใกล้กับ True Value มาก ตอนนี้
ทั้งหมดนี้มีต้นทุน และที่นี่เราเห็นว่า variance หรือความกว้างของ distribution เพิ่มขึ้น ซึ่ง
โดยทั่วไปไม่ใช่สิ่งที่ต้องการ แต่ทุกอย่างมีต้นทุน โชคดีที่เราสามารถจัดการสิ่งนี้โดยรัน
shot มากขึ้น ซึ่งทำให้ distribution ลดขนาดกลับไปยังระดับ uncertainty ที่ยอมรับได้ นั่นก็ประมาณนั้น
สำหรับบทเรียนนี้ ครั้งหน้าเราจะนำขั้นตอนทั้งหมดมารวมกันและดำเนินการตาม area และตัวอย่าง
ของ application ที่สนใจจริง ๆ มีหลายอย่างที่ฉันแนะนำให้ทำจนถึงตอนนั้น ถ้ายังไม่ได้ดาวน์โหลด
ให้แน่ใจว่าดาวน์โหลดและตั้งค่า Qiskit 1.0 คุณยังสามารถดูบทเรียนที่เกี่ยวข้องสำหรับบทนี้และ
ตอนก่อนหน้าบน IBM Quantum learning platform และสุดท้ายถ้าสนใจขุดลึกและ
เรียนรู้เพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับเทคนิค error mitigation ดูแหล่งข้อมูลมากมายที่ฉันลิงก์ไว้ด้านล่าง จนกว่าจะพบกันใหม่
[เพลง]